it's been two weeks since Sabah Hussein
last spoke to her son Yahya Salah told
her he was planning to travel by boat to
Europe she begged him not to so did his
father
was about a month ago my son approached
me and said father I want to travel I
refused but one night after I had fallen
asleep he took from his mother's money
he then left I started searching for him
but couldn't find him later I found out
that he borrowed some money from someone
and traveled to Libya I contacted people
there in Libya and tried to bring my son
back but no one cared the 18 year old
Egyptian is one of hundreds of migrants
feared dead they set sail from Libya for
Italy earlier this month the fishing
boat got as far as the Southwest coast
of Greece where it experienced engine
trouble and capsized
104 people are known to have survived
nine of them have been arrested and
faced charges including manslaughter and
human trafficking
lawyers for two of them say their
clients deny the charges
he claims that he was with 30 to 35
fellow Egyptians on the boat he left his
country looking for a better life in
Europe because of economic difficulties
my client denies the accusation he says
that he was also a victim and that he
also paid a sizable amount in Egyptian
currency to be transferred from Egypt to
Italy
European countries have been trying to
disrupt the people's smuggling business
and deter potential clients from
boarding their boats
still more than 77 000 migrants and
Asylum Seekers have made the treacherous
journey to Europe this year at least 1
300 died or disappeared along the way I
think pushback's disclosure of the
border the externalization of the
borders that we are putting in place in
Europe are creating
this bottlenecks this bottlenecks where
the people are stranded then they are
victims of criminality of criminal
networks that are the Smugglers and it's
not only Libya it's all around Europe
questions have been raised about how
this tragedy unfolded with the UN
calling for an investigation Greek
authorities say the crew of the sinking
boat rejected the Coast Guard's offer to
help
for those Left Behind knowing the fate
of their loved ones is all they're
asking for
we don't know how to bring him back
whether he is alive or dead and we don't
even know if he is missing what kind of
life is this we want to know the fate of
our son either he returns alive and may
God be protecting him or he turns into
coffee I am prepared to Bear whatever
has happened
Christina Harrison Al Jazeera